george is in a particular place uh when
we look at uh the situation there in the
situation in ukraine there are parts of
georgia that are
basically occupied by basically occupied
very occupied with two military bases
in each of the occupied territories
but how how does that uh you know point
of view from georgia when looking at
ukraine is there
a sense of similarity is there a feeling
that maybe georgia might be next
there is a sense of solidarity there is
a sense that we are
having exactly the same history because
we have gone through the same
history since
the russian empire to the soviet empire
to now russia and we have experienced
exactly the same things
we
think that we are already
occupied and we have already had this
this experience
so what is dominating is probably
not the fear it's probably solidarity at
this stage
the georgian population is really
feeling that it's another self that is
now under this attack
and we are looking with hope at the way
ukraine has been resisting
has been showing full unity as managed
to gather
support from
all its partners in europe as in the
united states
so we are really looking at that with
admiration you have numerous times
called for more support and more
attention for uh georgia
would that support also mean more
military support training uh weapons is
that also one of i think that we have we
can always have more defensive weapons
because that's all
georgia could do
but we've had
quite a number of trainings we had nato
training just two months ago
we have had the training directly on the
ground when georgian soldiers
were in quite numbers and together with
the germans in afghanistan
and we are really considered by by nato
as one of the good pupils of the
integration
policy so what we really need
is a quicker and surer path towards
integration both in eu
and nato because that's where we see
ultimate security
our ultimate security cannot be in a war
because we will never be able to win a
war with uh
russia georgia's population uh
is showing a lot of solidarity with
ukraine but there is some
dissatisfaction that the government
hasn't maybe done enough to show its
support for ukraine you have been very
outspoken and showing solidarity for
ukraine
is the government going far enough and
listening to what the the people are
asking for well you know the
ukrainians sometimes are asking more and
more
from their partners not only from
georgia they have had some harsh words
for different partners including the
last blinken when he was coming to
don't bring chocolates bring arms so yes
they would like to also receive arms
from georgia to have georgia opening the
second front all of that is not
possible so i think that
the government is just more realistic
about what georgia can do at this stage
having this
two occupied territories one of which is
now talking about a referendum to
join
russia
so clearly we have to be careful
because we don't have many means and
nobody would be ready to support georgia
in the in the same way but that does not
in any way change
the level of solidarity that we have
what the people are are saying when
criticizing the government is also that
maybe they're not uh
fully
embracing the sanctions and that uh the
position has been maybe a bit ambivalent
uh you know it has maybe been in words a
bit ambivalent again because not trying
to be not too provocative
uh but in fact georgia is fully applying
sanctions and we are seeing now the
the effects internally uh in the economy
on some very important
sides of the of the economy and we are
sharing
all the international sanctions
completely so what the government was
saying is that we are not adding to the
existing sanctions which we are
complying
and sometimes overly complying in order
not to be
we're not adding national sanctions but
we do not
know very well what would be the
additional national sanctions that
georgia could inflict upon upon russia
but that being said i think that the
public opinion
is on board it is a fine line to walk
trying to
not get russia angry against georgia
well many western countries have been
doing that for many many years
while being under the protection of both
article 5 and the european solidarity so
i don't think that one can expect from a
country that is on the
front anyway
and who has none of these protections
and there are only two countries like
that
among those that are very vocal
it's moldova and georgia all the others
beat the baltic states poland the border
countries
all of them are protected and very
protected as we have
heard
mentioned so many times that the
article 5
border and those that are on this side
and those that are on the other side um
georgia has put forward a formal
application to join the european union
uh what importance would it have for the
country were it to join the the union
it's not where it
it's uh
now a path that has become
a reality i think it's
thanks to
what the ukrainian
the war in ukraine uh has shown to the
european leaders that the
past the way it was provided for before
this long-term perspective that was
very lengthy
both in eu and nato in fact is not
giving those countries this sense of
belonging that
we after all these years
do deserve
and so the one of the ways to show
support for for these countries against
this uh
threat and aggression uh is to embrace
them
and i think that's the realization that
we are seeing now
germany has said it would support uh
georgia in this process but in the past
we've seen for example with joining nato
that germany has not necessarily been so
supportive of um
that membership happening soon
should germany and other european
countries have done more earlier um to
support georgia and in these endeavors i
would say yes but what i can say that
what i think very promising is that they
have changed now so i'm more interested
about the support today than about the
analysis of the past and i think that
it's remarkable
the way in which
germany has evolved
in its
vision of both europe of supporting
ukraine even supporting it very directly
and that gives us a lot of hope
i think in the same manner of france has
changed a lot and those are the
countries that traditionally were not
very enthusiastic about
this process of integration in both
direction
and i think it's something that is quite
spread among all the european leaders at
least those i've talked to and i think
that there is a kind of
consensus that is emerging on the fact
that
there should be this new approach you
don't think that if um european
countries had acted upon this sooner
maybe some of the events that we've seen
could have been prevented or some
countries in the region i do not like to
to change the weight of responsibility
from one side to the other
yes the
european countries and the united states
could have done more could have been
more vigilant could have been more
clear about what was the nature of
russia but they're further away than we
are they don't have the same experience
and that doesn't change to the fact that
there is only one responsible and that
is russia
we cannot put responsibility in an equal
manner on those that wanted to see
things to be different
wanted to believe that russia could
change uh wanted to believe that there
were things they could do and that's
something that is in the very nature of
the democratic states to
want the other uh to
be
like itself
and if it is not to try to help it
change to become like like us and
unfortunately that
doesn't happen
um is georgia ready do you think to
enter the european union there have been
some questions about
a spotty
application of civil rights um
of certain democracy we have clearly uh
not fulfilled all the uh requirements
for entering the european union and i
don't think that anybody is saying that
we would not do need to continue
and to accelerate also
the pace of reforms i think we have done
quite a lot
and frankly i don't think that
georgia is the worst democratic country
in the whole european union
and especially looking at where we come
from and in what conditions this is
happening
but i think that we will do much more
once we are
within rather than being left outside
where
after a while then you lose the support
of the of the population if it doesn't
look uh real enough
so i think that these new circumstances
are going to push us to
be more worthy
what is the mood in georgia are people
[Music]
afraid of what is happening in ukraine
with russia
and
yeah is there a feel that
george's may be vulnerable also to
russian propaganda and that that could
have an impact on the mood of the people
in the country
i think that there is concern
about what russia can do because clearly
it has shown that it can do everything
and there is no inner limitation to what
russia might be tempted to to do
so this concern exists i don't think
that it's
i would not qualify it as fear because
we have gone through
many of these things and so there is a
kind of resilience and use
the population is
used to this
to this behavior
and in terms of russian propaganda yes
it's
they're attempting to do that but there
too
georgia has been living under soviet
propaganda for
70 years and resisted to that propaganda
which was very organized
and i think that we are better
uh
[Music]
able to defend ourselves against
including fake news and propaganda
because of this
past than
some other countries
that have not known what it means to be
under complete
controlled
and distorted information
uh president surah vishvili thank you
very much for your time thank you